so a judge has denied a bid by Q Shaman
to toss out his January 6th conviction a
federal judge Thursday denied a bid by
January 6th right or Jacob chansley
better known as the Q Shaman they're
calling him Q Anon Shaman it's Q Shaman
okay to vacate how would you know that
though
to vacate his conviction in light of
footage not incoming investigation you
know this is I'm done for now HC sorry
um to vacate his conviction in light of
footage from the capitol that day aired
by X Fox News host Tucker Carlson
chansley who stood out from the January
6th crowd for wearing face paint and a
horned headdress I actually thought he
fit in pretty well I don't know if he
said during the riot pleaded guilty to
obstruction and was sentenced uh in
November 2021 to 41 months now this is
something I want to mention I was
obviously being a little tongue-in-cheek
there what happened on j6 was on one
side of the building
we did have people who broke through the
window and broke in on the other side of
the building the police literally opened
the doors and let people in so you had
just a lot of regular people who were
there as protesters who are walking
through and uh were catching charges
because of it it's crazy there was
actually a judge who had to let somebody
off because the footage that they had of
the event proved that he basically went
and told to spoke to a police officer
and he wasn't told that he couldn't
leave in order to charge someone with
trespassing they can't think that
they're allowed to be there but of
course we know that uh the left they
don't care about Law and Order at all
and that goes in two directions that
goes a in the direction of not
Prosecuting people who are breaking the
law and of course Prosecuting people who
didn't break the law and refusing to
exonerate someone even when footage
comes out showing that they were not
guilty of the crime of which they were
accused now that said in this particular
story
I can't give you all the intricacies and
details it's possible that they still
had something on him but overall with
the pattern that I've seen with these
hearings they're all too willing to be
as harsh as possible on people who
really either have a very good excuse or
actually didn't break the law at all uh
and there are some people who were
genuinely violent who should be locked
up there's no question about that but
again we don't see any of the people who
broke down the barricades at the White
House being arrested there was not an
investigation into the 2020 riots
despite a majority of the American
population wanting investigations
according to polling data far more
people than wanted investigations into
January 6 because the j6 you know
investigations were not about protecting
the American people or our democracy
they're about protecting people in power
and having you ignore the fact that
cities were literally set on fire and
allowed to burn for several months at a
time well it is a crime to withhold
exculpatory evidence and that's what the
36 committee yeah it's true did and and
if if that had been extended to other
famous cases you think of uh hands up
don't shoot you think of of of Kyle
Rittenhouse right when evidence comes
out different angles different cameras
different footage and you get to paint
the whole picture it somehow changes the
verdict a little bit because the jury
sees everything there was no jury
obviously in the j6 uh trial but the
fact that they withheld all of this and
obviously this footage wasn't brought
into Jacob chanslee's it's a shameful
for the judge right and it's shameful
for Benny Thomas and the entire j6
committee and all the people who partook
of it that's why the Republicans turned
so much on on on
um Liz Cheney why they turn so much on
Alan kinsiger not because they were part
of j6 but because they they knew that
they were withholding evidence like this
they knew that they were withholding in
crucial pieces of data to tell the full
story
um and wanted to for you know to at
Trump and that's that's an unforgivable
crime yeah I I mean I think you're right
this is a a complete perversion of of
Justice I I do remember reading that
story now that you mention it that
evidence was actually withheld I mean
again these people care nothing for rule
of law they don't care about the process
they care about the outcome yeah the
evidence that Tucker showed of the
Capitol Police walking Jake I saw that
yeah walking him up the stairs and the
door was locked they found another door
they opened up the door they walked them
to the floor of the cabinet Coco he gave
his prayer thank you Lord God Almighty
for the United States Senate thank you
for the Capitol Police for keeping us
safe and then they walked him out and he
went home yep uh so again people could
say well he still broke the law by being
there but that really changes things a
little bit from The Narrative that they
showed at j6 well I mean it's hard to
say that somebody is a trespasser when
police officers literally walk them
through the building and tell them that
they can be there I mean I mean you
would have thought if he was doing
something illegal they would have
perhaps been the one to notice it yeah
yeah it's kind of crazy I know that's a
crazy experience the police were in on
the Insurrection yeah but why are they
getting brought up on truck drivers well
because if that evidence showed who were
those cops those cops now have to test
if I why did you walk Jacob chancelly
and you get an order did you how did you
think and we already made the Capitol
Police the heroes of this story right
yeah I mean so unraveled I was um I got
the chance to sit in on opening uh on
when we did opening statements for the
proud voice trial this this group of
guys that were uh selected by the U.S
government to represent the masterminds
of the conspiracy right because there
were a couple people who they like
swapped in and out at the last minute it
was it was crazy uh but one of the
things that I remember the most and I
wrote about it for Tim cast news if you
want to find that article uh is uh
thanks thanks uh was that the US
government first and it was like here is
a clip of text messages they're having
or here is a video or here is a voice
moment and then all you know each each
man was represented by their own
attorney so there were a lot of
attorneys they had a lot of lots to say
but most of the time they just expanded
it instead of taking one tiny clip like
the US government they were like here is
the context of what they're saying and
it was very difficult to believe one of
the attorneys there said it best these
men couldn't organize ordering as a
group from McDonald's you think they
organized a conspiracy but the fact of
the matter is you know the U.S
government the in really the American
Media needs someone to take the fall
they need to have whipped the people
into a frenzy and they cannot say that
there was no one at fault here and that
to me is disturbing right because we are
not uh carrying out Justice for the
people we are carrying out Justice for
these corporations and the
administrative bloat that says we did
the right thing and we will prove it to
you with our own tools well even the
whole narrative surrounding January 6th
and the idea that it's an Insurrection
is so unbelievably ridiculous these
people were grasping at any straw they
can possibly grab out to try to indict
and criminalize Donald Trump or
prosecute Donald Trump make him out to
see him as if he was trying to subvert a
democratic process when in reality they
were doing that with this fraudulent
nonsensical investigation into Russian
interference in the 2016 election and
his collaboration with them when you
actually looked narrative what they're
effectively saying is that Donald Trump
the commander-in-chief
the president of the United States
the most powerful person on the planet
with all of the resources available to
the executive branch and his fingertips
wanted to overturn a fair and free
election and his genius plan to do so
was by dog whistling to a bunch of
Boomers to go inside of the capital and
not do anything violent yeah what
an incredible plan he literally said go
have your voices heard he didn't tell
them to be violent he told me
non-violent he told him to go protest
yeah not not break in but even so even
so if he had some kind of secret dog
whistle that only the other
conservatives could hear and that's why
they went in there it seems like a
pretty lame thing to dog whistle when
you're trying to overthrow the United
States government to get it to get a
group of people I mean it's the most
really was a mostly peaceful
Insurrection it was the only person who
was harmed the only person who was
harmed was one of the protesters poor
Ashley Babbitt that woman was that woman
was killed that woman was killed if
someone was killed at a BLM protest they
would be a martyr for the country I'm
not kidding we would have statues of
them we would have statues of them the
police officer who shot them would be
locked up we would melt the key down and
then pour the metals it was made of down
the drain
yeah I mean I think you're right so I'm
desperately digging in my backpack
because I have a relevant note I'm
looking for a point looking for a point
well I I someone told me that there was
another protester at January 6 who um
had a heart attack and then later died
but we don't hear his name so I'm just
trying to see if I can pull my notes on
this well but um well I mean I'll I'll
give you a second to find those but this
is something
journalists listen I think that person
is still on the mall actually yeah my
effects are right I think that person
would didn't even make it to the Capitol
and I think they were older I think they
were have Kevin Greeley has a name
nobody quote me on this media I'm just
looking back at my notes the media but
it is interesting because people did
suffer because of these rights and the
representation is that they were all
armed and dangerous and crazy and Donald
Trump sent them there and meanwhile uh
the video showed these supposed leaders
saying no one go in don't go in there
like this is the worst Insurrection ever
if the leaders who comp who apparently
conspired to do this are telling you not
to go go in there yeah that's a really
bad idea I just don't understand and and
especially because we did not see the
same kind of uh vicious pursuit of
people who really did burn businesses in
the summer of 2020 how can you say that
this is worth spending I'm gonna go back
to our first story uh millions of
dollars investigating right now become
we don't have a system of justice that
represents people outside of Washington
if you are an American voter and you had
a business that burned in in Minneapolis
or in any major city and you know that
they just said well we're gonna let them
go they didn't feel heard and it's okay
but because it happened to us the
federal government we are going to use
the full weight of our purse strings to
go after these so that's exactly right
fast it shifted Focus from like
everything else they were going after
Trump four and then all of a sudden like
I was watching it live and I'm like okay
so now this has happened everything else
was forgotten about essentially yeah and
the main focus and the show trial on
this for the next however many years
yeah All For What like it's crazy thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time